مسؤوليه مقاومه مثابره وشغف انا لامي ابنه
وخبيره تغذيه
[موسيقى]
كنت انا ردي عائشه مع امي واختي
خمس سنين ومن بعدها سملينا بالعيشه بدوحه
قطر لحد ما صار عمري 13 سنه لما عرفت انه
ماما مصابه بمرض السرطان من وقتها حسيت
انه هذه كانت لحظه صدمه لقلب فقلت اول شيء
انه بابا راح وهلا ماما
من بعد ان صار في خربطه بحياتنا تانى من
الدوحه قطر للبنان بظرف شهر كنت وقتها هذه
الصيفيه بلشنا نبرهم على مدارس وبنفس
الوقت ما عم بتشوف علاج لها هي نزلتنا على
لبنان كرمال انه بنظاره انه خلصت امنا عن
تيتا وشدته بحال انه هي توفت ليستمر
يهتموا فينا فانا هنا صار عندي مثل
المسؤوليه انه انا عند اخت اصغر مني بدي
اهتم فيها وبنفس اللي نزلنا عم بدرس
مسيرته
[موسيقى]
الجامعه الامريكيه ببيروت اعمل فيه مهنه
التغذيه
واختياره التغذيه من قبل قصه ماما هي انه
بالعاده دايما نحنا بنروح للعلاج فالتغذيه
بالنسبه
الوقايه خير من العلاج فليما مبلش من
ناحيه التغذيه نهتم على الاكل
هذا الطموح
ومن بعد التخرج وهيك جربت انه اعمل صفحه
على الانستغرام طبعا من بعد ما اشتغلت
وعملت الانتيم شاب وبعدين هلا على
الانستغرام
التوعيه همم من خلال التغذيه لصحه افضل
اوكي بعد انا باحس المسؤوليه عندي بهذا
العائله
ان همم انه انا ساعده مثلا اعطيها المصائب
حبكون يمكن امرار همم انه ستركت بهذا
الموضوع وبشرب انه مثلا اي شيء بيسال عملت
هيك سويت هيك فانه مثل كانه بحس حالي السل
بعد ما مسؤوله عن شخص همم اصغر من مثل ما
انا وصغيره يعني جاء هذا الشعور لالي
واستمرت فيه حلم ان شاء الله اني اقدر
هدفه اني انشر التوعيه عن طريق التغذيه
لصحه ابطال وقدر انه نوصل صوت لاكبر عدد
ممكن انا اكثر شيء هو الشرق الاوسط وبتمنى
انه بيوم من الايام انه يقدر اني اعمل
مايكاترين او ما يكون
براندن همم مواد صحيه
المراه انه ما تستسلم
اي عقبات ممكن تمرق فيها دائما في مخرج
همم
تحقق اهدافك
[موسيقى]